okay let's get into the redacted Moller
report it is difficult to go through and
find everything that's notable in a 400
page report particularly at this sort of
early stage and even being able to look
at it but I'm going to give you some of
the highlights of it and the bottom line
is that it's absolutely devastating to
the president if you can get around the
propaganda of the four-page bar letter
if you can get around the propaganda of
Trump's exoneration tour William bars
ridiculous Thursday morning press
conference where he assured us that
crimes that no one ever accused anybody
of committing certainly didn't happen
one example from William bars press
conference he said nobody on the Trump
campaign participated in the Russian
hacking who asserted that people on the
Trump campaign participated in the
Russian hacking a disgusting press
conference arguably one of the most
disgustingly political acts of this
entire thing making Donald Trump out to
be merely a victim when in reality even
the redacted version of the Moller
report which has many redactions as
you'll see in a second extraordinarily
damaging the Donald Trump into the
people around him and remember this
requires some nuance if your responses
are total exoneration or Trump clearly
should be in prison or Trump deserves an
apology just save it because there's a
lot of material here for the adults to
actually discuss and this is the time
for actually going through it piece by
piece and I'll just point out a few
things to you and we will have more
coverage of this some pages almost
totally blacked out I mean just almost
nothing there whatsoever and a lot of
the stuff that is blacked out is blacked
out on the basis of possibly causing
harm to an ongoing matter that's really
important because if we believe that as
the reason for some of these redactions
that means that there are countless
investigations still ongoing related to
the content of this report 12
investigations by one count 14
investigations by another account so now
the content of what's not redacted it's
important to consider
when we hear a general assessment of
something from the bar letter such as
the Special Counsel did not establish or
there was no evidence sufficient to
you've got to really go and look at the
report and look at the underlying
statements that the report makes so as
an example there is an incredible amount
of evidence of obstruction in Robert
Mulder's report even in this Unruh in
this redacted version now ultimately the
report says and this is extraordinarily
disturbing that Muller didn't charge
Trump with obstruction because there was
quote no underlying crime of personally
colluding with Russia which of course
who expected that to be found that the
obstruction attempts that Trump made
some were made publicly and thirdly
because charging Trump would create a
burden on a sitting president that would
impact their capacity to govern okay
that means that there was lots of
evidence of Trump obstructing but
Moeller ultimately made the decision not
to charge because some of the
obstruction happened in public and
charging the president with obstruction
would burden their ability to carry out
their duties those are political reasons
not to charge those are not legal
reasons not to charge and one of the
most telling elements of all of this is
that Trump believed he had done really
bad things this is a completely crazy
example Jeff Sessions testified
according to his chief of staff this is
in the report okay that Donald Trump
said when he found out about the
investigation quote oh my god this is
terrible this is the end of my
presidency
I'm effed how could you let this happen
Jeff you were supposed to protect me
this is the worst thing that ever
happened to me you do not say I'm effed
and this is the end of my presidency if
you've done nothing wrong and an
investigation is starting that you
believe is going to completely exonerate
you and clear you okay that is not how
someone reacts
they don't believe themselves that they
did something wrong which clearly Donald
Trump did the report even identifies
Trump's intent to obstruct by pushing
Jeff Sessions to hamper the probe if you
look at one particular section here
under intent
it says substantial evidence indicates
that the president's effort to have
sessions limit the scope of the special
counsels investigation to future
election interference was intended to
prevent further investigative scrutiny
of the president's and his campaigns
conduct it specifically says what the
intent was and people keep summarizing
this and showing that Trump didn't have
criminal intent and yet there are
countless quotes from the report which
say that Trump did intend to hamper the
investigation via his conduct whether he
knew it was a crime is actually
irrelevant here the report is also
filled with doublespeak I mean consider
these contradictions that appeared just
three paragraphs apart quote the
investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in its election interference
activities and a few paragraphs later
through that period of time and for
several months thereafter Papadopoulos
worked with myth sued and two Russian
nationals to arrange a meeting between
the campaign and the Russian government
that is members of the Trump campaign
coordinating with the Russian government
there's one other quote that's relevant
which you can also look at in the report
as far as the whole collusion thing
reminder never thought Trump was going
to be personally caught colluding it's
good to stop straw Manning that as many
people are a year and a day ago to this
day I made that clear and many times
since but remember when Donald Trump
answered questions in writing we knew
that not sitting down with Muller was a
really great thing for Donald Trump and
every single answer that Donald Trump's
attorneys submitted in writing was I do
not remember I do not recall check out
those pages in the report
were linking to not going to read them
all to you but Trump asked did you were
you aware of why and Trump says I have
no recollection of that were you
informed about Z Trump says I have no
recollection that I don't recall I don't
remember massive win I mean honestly
congratulations to Donald Trump's legal
team by not having him sit with Muller
able to respond to almost every question
with I don't remember or I don't recall
and that is a great way to get out of
criminal charges as we know so bottom
line as I said more than a year ago this
investigation was never going to remove
Trump from the presidency Democrats
counting on it as a strategy we're silly
to do so and now you've got to win in
2020 because they've done it perfectly
installing bar bars propaganda letter
and propaganda press conference a
decision from Robert Muller for
political reasons not to charge Trump
with obstruction you've got to hand it
to them and over the next few days we
will continue to comb through the
specifics of the report but they won and
we've just got to realize that the
report is extraordinarily damaging and
it appears that they have set it up so
that Donald Trump will avoid all
consequences send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show support
those who support the David Pakman show
and today that includes our good friends
over at BRD Bitcoin wallet these guys
are awesome and the BRD Bitcoin wallet
is absolutely perfect for anybody who's
getting into Bitcoin or cryptocurrency
for the first time because it was
designed with simplicity and ease of use
in mind but you'll also love it if you
have experience with Bitcoin it's an
all-in-one app for iOS and Android that
lets you buy Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies using your credit card
lets you store everything on the app for
free you can trade and sell
cryptocurrency within the app and when
you use BRD wallet you're the only
person who has access to your Bitcoin
BRD doesn't store any of your personal
information you don't even have nor do
you need
a username and password on the platform
it's all within an environment that's
virtually impossible to hack so your
cryptocurrency is safe extremely easy to
use
it's how I store my own Bitcoin I think
you'll be impressed with it too it's the
first ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App
Store and now they have over 2 million
users for more than 170 countries BR DS
mission is to make buying selling and
storing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies simpler more efficient
and more secure and they've done an
awesome job check out my interview with
Aaron from the BRD team we had a really
interesting discussion about the state
of cryptocurrency going forward you can
also download the BRD app for ios and
android i've put a link right underneath
this video